so tell me about your dad what was it
like growing up it was interesting
growing up you know with divorced
parents twice a month I would head over
there on the weekends and have a good
time so he was fun
absolutely it was always activities
going on there's always stuff to do it
was a very very lively experience being
at the home did you know what being a
hair stylist meant I did I spent a lot
of time at the salon
of course I understood what it you know
what it means to be a hairdresser but I
didn't quite understand the caliber of a
hairdresser that he was my father
so where there are times that you called
him when you weren't feeling so good and
he lifted your spirits I can't even
count the time he lifts your spirits he
changes her attitude he gets you
determined to charge the mountain of
life and he would absolutely turn your
mood around if we're having an awful day
so he was cool he was yeah he was hip oh
for sure I mean as far as far as dads go
I had a pretty cool dad yeah that's for
sure